i would like to welcome you all
for this today's webinar
where we will discuss about omix logic
training and research programs
today we will get you all started with
introductory coursework of your field of
interest and also discuss the stepwise
guidelines to proceed with the training
program completion to research
fellowship
research fellowship opportunities under
mental guidance as well
my name is sunalika ray and i'm the
omixlogic community manager and i'm
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community that is managed
by buying biotech
so before we start with the talk
i would like to introduce us we are a
u.s based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between fine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omixlogic training and research is
running internationally in eight
different regions and over fifteen
thousand users around the world have
completed the training so far
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine the
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
amish logic programs follow a
project-based learning approach using
research grade tools to analyze data
from top period review journals
omixlogic training has been completed
from 162 countries in over 1 300
workshops for six different
specialization tracks
being oncology infectious diseases
precision medicine neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on our mix data
analysis
now to introduce my team
i'm honored to have been working with
the team that collectively has an
amazing experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company dr alfred tauber who comes from
a medical background with an expertise
in oncology immunology and biochemistry
of information
and one of his major projects is the
establishment of the double
bioinformatics research center which has
been at the core of what we do
dr leonard brodsky is the director of
the tomber bioinformatics research
center and is an expert in
bioinformatics and biostatistics
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right
julia panna who is an expert
bioinformatician and has helped prepare
many of the materials that we will use
aviativsky who is a computer scientist
and leads the development of the team
info platform that we would be using dr
harpreet core has an expertise in the
application of statistical machine
learning techniques on biomedical data
and development of prediction tools and
databases and looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development
dr mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in industry and
academia
dr raghavendran is an accomplished
computational biologist with an
experience in large-scale analysis of
multi-army's data and data science
methods in precision oncology and
protein dna structural bioinformatics
so that was what i wanted to discuss
about our team and now i would like to
pass on the stage to mr elia broski ceo
by in biotech to talk about the various
training programs that have been
designed for the university over to you
thank you very much
and uh thank you everyone for joining
today's webinar so we're doing this
webinar
at the invitation of uh dr aman
teriya and we're excited to kind of get
this started so let me share my screen
i want to introduce you today to a
platform that we developed so that we
can
facilitate effective training as well as
a transition into research using
computational biology and bioinformatics
and we hope that some of you will be
able to register today and try some of
the things out so registration itself is
free
i want to go through some of the basic
features so if you could please all
navigate to learn.omixlogic.com
i will just kind of show you around in
the beginning and then i will proceed to
discuss
about some of these specific training
opportunities that we will have as well
as how does this apply to actual
research using bioinformatics
so i'll give it a moment
uh if you go to learn.omikslogic.com
you will see right here on the top there
will be a
login
button
and then you have to just fill out some
basic details and then you will have a
profile
and this profile will collect all of the
information
that you will be
kind of accumulating over time as you go
through some of the examples that we
have prepared
but also i will describe later on how
you can find here some specific types of
training and certification that is now
offered through the louisiana biomedical
research network
which covers
many different primarily undergraduate
institutes across the state of louisiana
but also is a part of a larger network
of universities across the u.s called
the national association of principal
investigators and we have been
contracted to facilitate some of the
training and bioinformatics for the
whole network
so
please let me know if you had the chance
to
log in
you can
just you know say yes or
put something in the chat so that i know
again the link is
learn
omixlogic.com and i'll just take a
moment to show everyone how to use this
site
okay so
um the onyx logic portal is really
designed to
address some of the gaps in
computational biology and data science
for biomedical data
using a number of different tools that
we will review today but starting from
the very basic training so if you're not
familiar with many of the concepts in
computational biology and bioinformatics
and big data analysis we'll talk about
that
and then proceeding on to specialized
applications of bioinformatics in
several different domains and so here if
you scroll down you will see some of
those that we are focused on which is
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture and
importantly it is
facilitated by our cloud-based
infrastructure that is for big data
analysis as well as for coding and data
science exercises that i will explain in
the context of our data science training
as well
okay so let me just give it
just another minute
okay
so um as i mentioned uh the registration
itself here is free all you need to do
is create an account once you have
created an account you can complete your
profile and that will give you
additional benefits that i will talk
about in the future
and
especially it's important for this
process of certification so the way that
this portal works is it tracks your
activity providing you suggestions on
what are the next steps for you to go to
and as a result of completing either the
synchronous training that is just
available on the portal or some of the
programs that we will discuss in a few
minutes you will be able to get the
certificate and depending on which
university or organization you're from
it is going to be adapted to that as
well
and after you have completed the basic
profile you also have the opportunity to
work on an independent project and so
this is in reference to what sonarika
already mentioned a transition from
basic training to actual research so
after completing your profile and
following the directions which includes
accumulating a certain number of points
10 000 points which you get for
different kinds of activities you're
able to then submit a project proposal
and design a computational biology or a
bioinformatics project from identifying
a data set to performing your analysis
and finally submitting somewhat of a
poster presentation or essentially a
preparation for an article now the
benefit of this process is that along
the way you have training materials to
explain every stage
facilitate kind of training and practice
with the different methods and also get
feedback
from our expert network that will be
able to evaluate your project and today
at the end of today's session i will
describe how you can use some of this
information
in the end when you
actually want to present your research
to others
okay
so first of all about the basic training
what kinds of things can you actually
find on here so there are several
different sections here when you go on
the portal you will be redirected to a
page for courses and you can just simply
search for courses uh courses that
include some very basic things like
bioinformatics and python or specialized
things like a description of a project
data set with some of the methods that
were used in the publication that you
can try to perform yourself and compare
your analysis results with the analysis
that the authors did
so these are organized by several
different tags
including tags by data type like
transcriptomics or genomics
course or a project so if you're
interested to try a project you maybe
already know the basics of
bioinformatics you want to apply it to
specific type of a data set you can try
that and then also we have different
types of levels either more technical
like coding in r and python or more user
friendly where you can use our tbi info
data platform that allows you to process
data and analyze it without the need of
coding
you can also find the same topics kind
of highlighted below these are
essentially collections of courses
dedicated to a specific type of data or
an overview of different applications
that you can use
and then finally there are also programs
and one of the things that we recommend
to those that don't have a background in
bioinformatics is really to highlight
this getting started button
the getting started button essentially
gives you an overview of three important
topics that you can cover in a short
period of time and then you will be
introduced to some of the coding
practices in r in python so introduction
to bioinformatics is a free course that
you can complete maybe in an hour or so
really it gives you the applications of
bioinformatics that you can evaluate
from healthcare to agriculture
bites and molecules which is an overview
of some of the basic terminology and
some of the introductory materials to
topics like transcriptomics or genomics
or metagenomics
and then an introduction to
bioinformatics and r
and in python are really some
introductory materials to get you
started with this
challenge of coding now as you progress
further
you will be able to build on top of
these basic skills and really get into
more of the advanced training that i
will describe briefly in a second
now
today in this presentation we will only
sample some of this material again i
recommend going back but just to explain
i want to highlight what are some of the
key topics that you can find on this
portal
so the
basic kind of training and this is basic
training that has been standardized
trying to kind of address some of the
typical applications of bioinformatics
different types of data
so i already mentioned introduction to
bioinformatics
the specific types of omics like
genomics transmitomics metagenomics and
epigenomics which includes analysis of
whole exome and whole genome sequencing
for somatic mutations in german
augmentation analysis for example in
cancer transcriptomic data analysis
rna-seq for bulk and single cell rna-seq
data
metagenomics 16s ribosomal rna and
epigenomics and epigenomics includes
both
genome
wide methylation and chipseek
and then the final kind of a collection
of courses is a training in data science
for coding statistical analysis and
machine learning and this is especially
focused on these different types of onyx
data so we call it for biomedical data
so the
different basic skills that you might
gain from completing some of this
training
now are applied in very different
domains and these include oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience and
agriculture and because these domains
have specific considerations about the
type of data that is being generated but
also what is it implying what is the
information does it contain we separate
this into specialization tracks
essentially by using these project
examples from these different domains
but also providing you with mentor
guided program resources and so a
program and today i will speak primarily
about these mentor-guided programs that
are coordinated with the louisiana
biomedical research network so
essentially they are provided on a
semester basis so right now we're in the
fall semester and
the upcoming semester starts in january
where you will find essentially
three or four programs per semester that
you can choose from and get
certification from the louisiana
biomedical research network as a
professional certificate
but also as i mentioned a as a part of
the greater national association of
principal investigators which is a
network that covers 23 states and puerto
rico
so what are these programs
first of all programs are supported by
the program resources that you will
already find on this portal
and that means that you will have access
to asynchronous materials big data
analysis platform where you can analyze
large data sets quickly
coding exercises that you can complete
in your browser and an in-depth review
of project data sets that have been
curated specifically around the topic of
that program
and so today we'll talk about several of
those examples but i just want to again
remind everyone that this is applicable
to both people that are maybe more
comfortable already in a coding language
like r or python or that have no
experience in coding and for that we
have the user-friendly t-vine info
platform so the objective of these
programs is to explain the logic of big
data analysis and be able to perform and
try it to then learn the technical
skills to kind of appreciate the
impact sorry the impact of data science
in biomedical data and then also to be
connected to a network of mentors that
can help you address some of the
technical issues and get you beyond kind
of the typical online educational
challenge which is that you know once
you face a challenge there's nobody to
talk to and so that's where we really
provide that support to get you beyond
some of these technical things
so because
today's webinar is specific to tulane
university and so we have selected some
of the topics that we think are maybe
the most appropriate for this audience
but again if you explore this website
you'll be able to see some of the
additional things that are covered in
some of our training programs and so the
first example that i would like to start
with today is covet 19 sequencing for
variance of concern
so it seemed like this epidemic has
really brought to the forefront some of
the applications of bioinformatics for
genomic sequencing and population health
and especially we see now a resurgence
of interest because of this omicron
variant and one of the important things
that we see in this specific application
of bioinformatics is the link between
phenotype for example transmission level
or severity of infection
the genomic variation or variance and in
this case the word variant doesn't mean
a single mutation like we're used to in
the genomics for mammalian organisms but
really means a combination of variants
because these are viral
mutations that accumulate very fast over
time as well as um things like
geolocation and time so phylodynamics
and then finally the
the kind of relationship between
sequence and structure and so that is
really the objective of this training
and it is sort of based on some of the
publications that have been uh you know
recently in the um in in high impact
journals that speak about you know the
variants that are commonly studied like
variants of concern as well as the small
kind of unnoticeable variants when we
talk about consensus analysis so these
are
kind of lower frequency mutations that
we learn to analyze and i will talk a
little bit more about this in a few
slides
now the second example is single cell
transcriptomic so single cell
genomic data analysis and transcriptomic
data analysis have become a an important
focus to really understand in detail
what happens at the individual cell
level and how do different cells
describe conditions
based on the proportion of types of
cells so cell type
and cell biomarkers are very important
there but also change over time and so
these are the two things that we really
cover in this kind of training for
single cell transcriptomics and i will
be excited to share that you know we
have a number of tools and resources for
learning some of those
and i will talk about that in detail in
a little bit
the other one is again for designs or r
and python for bioinformatics so
we um have a you know kind of real life
for
biologists one of the major challenge
challenges in bioinformatics is becoming
comfortable with this way of dealing
with data by learning how to code and
maybe starting off with a library of
scripts that you can
leverage to make your analysis faster
and so in this data science training
that i will describe today
this is really one of the objectives is
to explain the logic of analysis when
different statistical methods and
machine learning methods or
visualization methods are applied to a
particular
biological kind of an experiment
how to run them and how to understand
the results and then to have access to
these snippets of codes that you
effectively learn to modify so that you
can apply them to a data set of your own
and really to understand how this code
works so that you understand the
significance of specific portions of
that code or how to glue it together
into a sequence of steps that you can
then perform
and then finally the last example that
we will briefly talk about in terms of a
specialization training that is coming
up
is structural biology or how to apply
chemo informatics
to understand the relationship between
structures and compounds and how to
kind of learn to investigate different
aspects of structural biology and
chemical information about molecules to
understand how it is typically applied
in a in the context of different
challenges that are typical for
biotechnology and pharmaceutical
industry
now as you can see a lot of these topics
rely on different types of omics data
and so because of that one of the major
things that we are
that we are going to be focused on is
multi-omics integration so one of the
challenges in multi-omics integration is
both the sense of very different data
types
types of data that describe different
levels of vomits like genomics or
transcriptomics and then how to combine
that information when we know that
really this information speaks about
same biological phenomena
and so to kind of talk about all of this
i want to briefly introduce the
t-bioinfo platform which is essentially
designed to help process
as well as integrate multiple types of
omics for multi-omics studies
and so to look at multi-omics
let's go to
server.tbio.info and i will type that in
right here
and i'll share the link
in the chat here as well
thank you sparsh
okay so this uh account will actually be
automatically created for you after you
have created an account on this learn
portal so after you create an account
within 24 hours you will also be given
access to this platform as well and this
is to let you analyze
and
interpret or integrate multiple types of
omics data but again the training for
how to use this platform is also
available
here as courses and also if you just
want to get started we have a section on
tutorials right here where you will also
find
a number of very short kind of you know
tutorials to get you started
okay so what is this platform so this
platform was designed to help you
process big data in sections like
transcriptomics
genomics or metagenomics down here below
and then to be able to analyze the
relationships between features of each
one of these different data types
and understand them either as an
integration so right here you have data
association and integration or for data
mining where we have machine learning
unsupervised and supervised machine
learning and then we also have some
specialization sections for cancer
biology and virology
so to illustrate how this platform works
i want to give you a brief example and i
want to highlight that under many of the
sections we have this drop down arrow
and the drop down arrow allows you to
sample one of these projects with a demo
pipeline
so the demo pipeline i will use today is
right here for rna-seq for the cell line
project
and i want to
you know the point of this presentation
is to really demonstrate that it is very
user friendly and follows a very
specific logic of analysis that will be
very easy to understand after this
illustration
so obviously we start with this button
called start
and here you have a brief overview of
the major steps for for bulk rna
sequencing data analysis so we have to
first pre-process the data or prepare
the raw data that we have for analysis
map the data onto the reference genome
or transcriptome and then quantify the
results of our analysis so we actually
have a structured table with individual
genes and numbers that signify how their
level of expression varies across our
sample set
so once we click on ok you can see that
i have a number of next steps that have
been highlighted and now based on my
understanding of these steps you can see
the color coding so all of the
pre-processing steps are in blue
all of the mapping steps are in red so
mapping on genome or mapping on
transcriptome
and the quantification is in green
and so now i have different options so
i'm going to start with pre-processing
or preparing the reads for the analysis
i will also perform pcr clean which
helps address the bridge pcr
amplification which is a part of the
sequencing process and then i can either
map on the transcripts or map on the
full genome now the difference is
obviously the alternative splicing right
how do i evaluate differences between my
samples or conditions which are groups
of samples at the level of genes which
are not typically what's actually
produced into proteins but it's the
transcripts right with alternative
junctions between exons and that we call
collectively uh
alternative splicing so i can either
perform
high sat2 for mapping on the genome and
kind of developing a novel transcriptome
by constructing isoforms or how
individual exons are spliced together
making a new gtf file which i will save
for mapping on the transcriptone
and then finally at the end
quantification and so the objective of
quantification as we already said is
preparing this table of
gene expression or isoform expression
with a number per sample or per column
right here
so this is an example pipeline
where we can end or go to differential
gene expression
and now we can quickly see the results
and the results as you can see are
either
gene expression
or
a form expression and so very quickly as
you can see
you can now look down and kind of
remember the steps that we took because
they're color-coded they're organized
into a logical workflow and now once
you've got a few examples of data sets
that you can work with you can really
appreciate how quickly you can get from
raw data to structure data so now you
have tables of expression
now once you have the tables of
expression what do you do with those
tables of expression so there are
typically two major approaches one
approach is to understand statistical
variation between groups of samples or
differential gene expression
differential gene expression can provide
us with deep insights into biology that
is represented by this transcriptomic
quantified data and for that we need to
annotate individual genes into groups of
genes with pathway or gene ontology
downstream analysis and so we have over
here a section that essentially combines
by inputting our raw data or the gene
expression data the the table of
expression to differential gene
expression and then enrichment and gene
set enrichment analysis which are
downstream steps to map pathways and
understand how biological processes
could be evaluated through the lens of
this transcriptomic data
the second major approach is machine
learning right when we have data sets
where we suspect individual samples to
be grouped into new groups right groups
that we have no
additional phenotypic information about
we are essentially mining our data to
find associations between samples or
even features like genes
and then try to understand what might
they mean how are they related to each
other and why and so clustering
and we have here a number of different
clustering methods implemented as well
as network analysis or typical
approaches for data mining with some
visual interpretation using things like
pca
and then the second approach is when we
have some kind of phenotypic information
or let's say clinical information and we
know that we have several different
types of samples maybe two or three or
four and we would like to classify this
data or perform supervised analysis and
for that we also have a number of
methods for classification and
regression
so
these are some of the standard methods
and of course as i mentioned one of the
major objectives of specifically this
platform is to provide multi-omics
integration capabilities and for
multi-omits integration a major
challenge is not just the ability to
integrate but also to understand what
are the many different approaches that
exist
and
how do they compare
and so to briefly speak about this
challenge of multi-omics integration i
wanted to invite dr raghav
who will speak about his research
project
on patient-derived xenograph models as
an example of multi-omics integration
for selecting
drug treatment for individual patients
thank you very much elia uh
good morning to everybody i would now
yeah i will share my screen and let's
start
okay
i am raghavendran i am a research
consultant and mentor with biopine
biotech and homage logics i am trained
in bioinformatics and i hold a phd in
computational biology from explanation
to germany my research interest and
focus is on data science techniques such
as machine learning and deep learning
applied to integration of multi-omics
data like gene mutation data gene
expression data and copy number
variation data
my role in omics logics is developing
curricula and mentoring students in the
research fellowship program
please let me talk about one such
example where i develop machine learning
models to predict tumor response for
variety of treatment options by
employing multi-omics integration of
gene expression data with gene mutation
and also with copy number variation data
so we know that cancer is is the leading
cause of vc states worldwide so for such
a dreadful disease systematic cancer
treatments have relied on
chemotherapeutic drugs that are
marginally more toxic to cancer cells
than normal cells this is a huge problem
because on an average only 25 percentage
of the cancer patients respond to cancer
drugs but in comparison about 80
percentage of the cancer 80 of the
patients respond positively to popular
painkillers available a prominent
solution to this problem is precision
oncological therapy where a treatment
strategy is designed by targeting the
molecular characteristics of the
patient's tumor hence the treatment is
personalized to patients who are likely
to respond positively to the specific
cancer therapies
there is no so there is not sufficiently
enough data from cancer patients to
molecularly characterize the tumors
under multitude of different
treatment options that are available
hence we have to resort to suitable
model systems
and in this case the model systems is
patient-derived genographs which are
immunocompressed immunocompromised mouse
models so we have covered why we have to
do this study already so uh how it is
done is
such is like this
the tumor cells from the cancer patients
are subjected to next-gen sequencing
techniques and the information about
gene expression
gene mutation and copy number variation
were extracted this data molecularly
characterizes the tumors and the tumor
samples that were extracted were then
grafted into immunocompromised mouse
immunocompromised mouse and administered
several cancer
treatment
cancer drugs
then these then the response of these
tumors to the respective drugs are
documented and these responses are then
categorized into the tumors responding
positively or negatively to the
treatments provided so this data records
the tumor's reaction to different tumors
both the molecularly
molecular characterization data and the
treatment response data are available
along with the publications so such
ability of data
generally generates a lot of research
questions
my research interest in this using
particular using this data is was to
design and implement machine learning
models to predict tumor responses to
different treatments that were tried so
most biomarkers obtained
obtained today for cancer include only
one ohmic measurement at a time and thus
they do not take full advantage of the
entire complexity of the systems
captured in multiomics data there are
however multiple approaches
exist for performing such multi-omics
integration as you can see from here
selecting the appropriate strategy to
discover complementary information that
are present in the omix data in and
converting them into a set of meaningful
features is still a very difficult
challenge and for this particular data i
had to employ um this late set of
multi-omics integration because mainly
predom other methods did not yield a
very positive results and also did not
provide a possibility to retain
interpretability of the
machine learning model
so what what actually happened and what
did we find uh the accuracy of the
machine learning model that i developed
was
measured as a
measured as matthews coordination
coefficient
where a plus one of this correlation
coefficient would mean
higher prediction accuracy for the
machine learning model and minus one
would mean a very low prediction
accuracy
and a random prediction accuracy is
considered anywhere around zero so
traditionally oh sorry
so traditionally single gene biomarkers
that was identified to be related to the
onset of cancer was also employed to
predict treatment response this is not a
very accurate model and it has been
shown in multiple different variety of
ways and i also show it in this
particular way where i apply this to
breast cancer when i use single gene
biomarkers to predict the treatment
response the treatment response was very
very poor but immediately when i employ
multiple gene uh information
instead of the single gene biomarkers
that prediction accuracy of the machine
learning model improves very well and
when i include uh
other omics data such as copy number
variation and gene x and somatic
mutation gene expression data the
prediction accuracy improves very uh
dramatically and we get a nice set of
distribution around the prediction
accuracy that was observed
for a different multitude of different
treatment profiles so
what more could be done with such a data
or with such a model machine learning
model one can actually extrapolate such
an analysis to include patient data from
tcga repository that would reveal us the
performance of these machine learning
models that are trained on pre-clinical
data such as most models
but tested on the real-world patient
data and when if one performs that when
one performs that one can identify the
caveats and when one can address those
uh issues where this model is found
deficient and of course one can perform
uh gsea analysis on a set of most
informative genes that were extracted
from the machine learning models uh
to identify specific biomarkers that can
explain the tumor sensitivity or the
tumors resistivity to different
treatments that were administered so
to perform such an analysis coding was
an integral part of my uh regime but if
one finds coding challenging then that
should not deter them from asking such
interesting questions and this is where
i think comics logic omixologic platform
bridges that gap by providing not only
the necessary training and also
providing a lot of alternative platform
to perform such an impactful research
without the necessity to learn coding in
such a great detail i thank you all for
your patience and i hand over the stage
back to elia
thank you very much dr
and
as we saw in this example
we essentially see how multi-omics
integration
methods are critical for
classification and in this case
prediction of treatment response
and of course many such interesting
challenges and projects could be
developed and so for anyone who's
interested on the portal we have a
number of different types of examples
for example cancer macrophages modeling
cancer precision medicine where similar
questions about
biomarkers subtypes of cancer and
response to treatment are being asked
using cell line data
pdx tumor microenvironment or patient
derived xenograft model microenvironment
role in development of cancer
but also applications to other
non-cancer projects like
response to malaria infection response
to drought resistance in potato
cultivars and also an introduction to
tcga the cancer genome atlas
so now let's switch gears
and i want to briefly speak about other
topics that i already described in the
beginning but in a little bit greater
detail because we do have an ongoing
program with lsu baton rouge
facilitated through the louisiana
biomedical research network on
transcriptomics
and so transcriptomics as you can see
all of these projects are based
primarily on transcriptomic data so
there's really a lot of questions that
you can ask of transcriptomic data
whether it's bulk rna-seq or single cell
rna-seq data and single cell rna-seq
data is becoming more and more
interesting in the context of immunology
neuroscience and many other different
applications and so recently we have
developed a process for kind of taking
that single cell rnaseq data
and preparing tables of expression which
in itself is a major challenge to do it
accurately
and so there are a number of different
tools that are available on the platform
just to process that single cell rna-seq
data but also as anyone familiar with
downstream analysis it is also full of
many technical challenges that have to
do with normalization
integration of multi-sample
data sets and also downstream
interpretation for example markers of
specific cell types
and so what we have done is we have
developed a course
around these challenges and now are
using this to both help researchers work
with their data and we're working with a
number of different groups that are
using 10x genomics as their primary
sequencing platform to identify
meaningful insights from single cell
data but also for anyone who would like
to learn
about these different challenges in
single cell rna-seq data analysis we
provide a tutorial
that talks about
processing that data and then using
packages like silverad and monaco to
understand both differential gene
expression between different cell types
and populations and also discover
trajectories across pseudotime to
evaluate development and specialization
of different cell types and we also are
in the process of developing a number of
project examples
where we have for example this project
detecting activated cell populations
using single cell rna-seq which is a
view of different types of neurons in
the mouse brain and how it could be an
integration process between
single cell rna seq data and profiling
of cell types
together with
kind of an understanding of response to
signal and networks in the brain
so really fascinating projects and so as
we both have described
we have these different training modules
that are designed to prepare you to
perform your own analysis we have uh
different methods like processing
analysis and integration
of multi-homage data
and now i briefly want to introduce
several specialization programs that are
starting in january so it's a good time
to think about how this might be
relevant to either research that you are
planning or how it might be relevant to
kind of leveraging some of these
computational biology and bioinformatics
skills to be able to perform this
analysis and maybe even work with others
to develop research projects
but before we go on i wanted to just
pause here for a second and ask if there
are any questions that any of you might
have
either about the project that dr raghav
just presented
or about what we have covered so far
and
iman maybe you could let me know if
there are any questions so we can
briefly address those now
i can hear me
yes yeah uh i'm iman to the hygienist
assistant biostation in bioinformatics
department of surgery italian university
i'm glad that we all joined today to
discuss this great learning opportunity
for computational biology
and um actually we are dealing with a
growing amount of biomedical data in a
variable time with variable types and we
are in much need to analyze such as it
in an efficient way to reach to a data
driven hypothesis and make use of what
we have formed
at an output from our lab work uh what's
we presented today uh a lot of various
types of platforms in addition to
integrating all these together this will
not only provide uh a platform that run
our analysis quickly but also provide
opportunity to learn step-by-step uh
different modules in guide us from a to
z to achieve our research objectives
from designing before going into the lab
and guiding us during hands-on analysis
exploring unnoticeable discoveries
tell achieving bulkable things as poster
presentation international publication i
started some of the platforms with the
omic logic a few months ago it was
amazing i i got to know two more
bioinformatic domains that was a black
spot for me
genomics chapstick single cell
transcriptomics efficient
along with in extending my knowledge in
the r and bython coding it it inspires
me of more
a tools that i can use and expanded my
my thoughts on creating more
study designs and helping me in
applications for grant um grant proposes
so i really really appreciate uh the
team effort
to deliver that the platform in a very
simple way step by step and i appreciate
all who joined us today in this webinar
yeah i really appreciate that uh the
effort that just if you if you really go
into the website you will find look at
the courses it's clearly explained in uh
with the screenshots with captures and
guided by a wonderful team that at any
time you can send the questions so
i really advise to uh to go through this
fellowship or at least some of the
courses it will guide you in a lot of
modules across the steps of multiple
domains across omics and will enable you
to build your career at the end thank
you team for ever uh making this happen
to multiple researchers and students
thank you very much uh iman and uh you
know really looking forward to get to
know um some of the others here in the
webinar and and discussing how this
might be applicable to what you might be
interested in your area of research and
so in the next um a few slides and i
will make it um you know quick
and we'll just go over a couple more
examples i already mentioned in the
beginning but we'll just provide a
little bit more detail and um kind of
speak about what could be the
application of that particular topic
in the context of you know what's
happening around us and and what's
happening in the next few months in the
context of our training programs
so one of the major
areas that we
are involved in in a variety of
collaborations
and this includes collaborations with
university like
university of california san francisco
haifa university where the tower
bioinformatics research center is
louisiana state university and others is
the domain of infectious diseases and so
for the infectious disease domain
you know applications like genomic
sequencing of pathogens as well as host
response on the human or animal model
side
are all very different
types of applications of bioinformatics
that are critical in a variety of
recently kind of you know highlighted
challenges with
public health so obviously we have the
top kind of things on the list like
source code 2 which i'll talk about in
detail
after this but also some of the other
kinds of kind of major
challenges with emerging diseases like
enterovirus ebd68 a disease that affects
children or malaria infection in
response to vaccines there have been
recently novel vaccine candidates that
are being advanced into uh later stages
of clinical trials or the recent
you know highlights of the ebola virus
epidemic in africa right how can we
learn from these outbreaks of infectious
diseases to really understand the role
of bioinformatics and because maybe of
these outbreaks that have been happening
recently there is now such a rich source
of publicly available data that we can
leverage to both learn about but also
perform analysis to understand and study
some of these emerging pathogens so to
speak about this i will use the source
code 2 example and i'll mention uh
source code 2 as an example because also
we have ongoing collaborations with a
number of universities
on sequencing waste water to understand
and detect outbreaks and and also detect
variants of concern so for sars grove 2
a number of different pipelines have
been developed over the past couple of
years where primarily we focus on
consensus level analysis of variance and
phylodynamics where we understand the
relationship between strains they're now
categorized into alpha beta gamma etc
and
how are they related to
time course so how do they change over
time as well as how can we tie them to
specific locations so i think a very
interesting
type of an analysis
widely used in the media to describe the
pandemic and some of the emerging
variants of concern including omicron
but also
importantly it only provides us with a
high level view of some of the major
challenges for this virus interacting
with the new host right so
breaking out potentially through
zoonotic transmission to humans and now
developing into a an adapted strain that
is very effective at transmission
causing a very specific disease uh so
now as we describe this pathogen right
one of the challenges is to also
understand what are some of the
ongoing processes within the host within
smaller groups of patients around the
world
and how do these variants of concern
emerge
and so here we have some additional
topics that we speak about in this
training like detection of novel
variants so how do you determine what is
a novel variant as opposed to some
random mutation how do we look at
subconsensus and low frequency variants
which essentially eventually become the
dominant kind of
genotype
and also how do we deal with some of
these
low
quality samples to understand uh whether
we can in a you know in a very um maybe
uh you know confident way say that there
is some variant or not
and then ultimately to understand how
can we map these variants onto protein
structure
using software like chimera
x
where we can look at the relationship
between variants and their position on
the spike protein for example and
understand interaction with other
proteins
and also how can we look at the host
response and understand which variants
are associated with what type of a
disease condition so first of all an
easy way to get started with all of
these topics is by taking a look we have
a course on the on the portal that i
just uh
showcased the onyx logic
portal where you can get an introduction
to many of these topics so how to uh use
some of the open
data sources where you can find genomes
and analyze those genomes how to perform
phylogenetic analysis to determine the
origins and maybe similarity between
different strains of viruses how to
understand the differences between
different
families of coronaviruses how to map
those variants onto the protein
structure
and also how to understand the response
to treatment for covid19 patients so how
do we understand those pathways of jack
stat pathway for inflammation and things
like that so it's a great resource to
get started
and
also learn some of these uh techniques
using the tbi info platform right so
before going into the coding you deal
with raw sequences many of them how do
you integrate all of that and get easy
to understand results and so there
we have developed specialized pipelines
that are essentially going to produce a
number of tables that you can use to
visualize and and kind of understand the
general patterns and then the second
part of the training is really focused
on producing clinical reports in r
where you will find uh a mapping
statistics uh the prominent areas that
should be analyzed for example spike
protein and then determining and calling
variants uh for example you can see here
variant in summary for the uk
201 uh 20i 501 y v1 right so how do you
actually perform that kind of analysis
and also learning how to code everything
from the beginning to the end using the
output pipelines the output from the
pipelines to produce such a report and
essentially this is going to be useful
for anyone who's involved in this kind
of public health domain or just wants to
understand how is this pandemic
developing over time
finding associations between
where the original kind of you know
source of infection is how is it related
to transmission and maybe even
understanding some of the response to
treatment like vaccines
and maybe some of the antivirals that
are coming on the market so a lot of
interesting questions that could be
asked
so the additional part of this is really
understanding the relationship between
sequence and structure how can we not
only know that this mutation happened in
a specific position on the genome but
also understand the amino acids the
protein is folded so how could we map
variability found in this genomic data
and then try to associate that
variability with what we know about the
interaction between different proteins
so here for example
you can see
an example of some of those
key mutations cluster around the
receptor binding domain as well as here
we can now
sorry
we can now see how it binds to the ace
to human receptor and so that gives a
very clear picture about the impact of
some of these mutations on the typical
function right so in this case
adaptation from um
from one organism to another in
adaptation specifically for cell entry
so the other um
second kind of training and for example
for the data science training
we have a program that we have ongoing
right now primarily for lsu
graduate students and faculty but we
will have a new program that's focused
on data science methods
for
all of louisiana and beyond as well
through the nepean network that will be
starting in january so in january 2022
we will have an announcement made
through all of the different channels
that we use for communication with the
specific dates and i believe today
sonalika will be able to share some of
those dates as well
so what is included in this data science
training
so in data science training we start
with just some basics in both r and
python so how to load different sequence
data different structure data like
tables how to develop a sense of syntax
what is in the syntax and you will find
on these
portal lessons that i've already shown
an inline practice area so this is a
console
in the console you get an assignment a
task
once you understand the syntax write it
out inside this console and check for
the results
and for example here the result is a
line multiple sequence alignment and
identification of specific variants and
then in the assignment you will have a
challenge for interpretation how do you
actually interpret one mutation versus
the others
in terms of its impact on the sequence
overall
now many of the methods that we use in
bioinformatics and data science are
you know packaged together effectively
in these easy to call methods and so the
syntax here is not just learning how to
write basic code but also familiarity
with some of the standard packages that
are used to produce publication ready
figures and so in this case
just an example of several of those that
could be used to develop
methods that you
learn how to use effectively packages
that you learn how to use effectively
and then produce the kinds of
visualization that you might expect to
find in a publication and use that to
both understand how the different
settings are designed and how to modify
them for the specific type of data that
you're working with and then make it
presentable so that you can share it
either in a poster in a publication or
just an internal report so that's really
the focus of this type of a program the
program is designed around several
different topics for example data
wrangling how to just manipulate
different complex data structures and
organize them developing a sense of a
preparation technique machine learning
and statistics unsupervised and
supervised types of analysis machine
learning
how to
try and compare different types of
machine learning techniques and really
understand why we would use one or the
other in what application and then also
an introduction to deep learning
so those types of topics are all
going to again be starting in january
and just to kind of briefly describe the
process you will be introduced to
examples of code
the code will be you know clearly
explained with the different aspects of
what that code syntax really looks like
and then you will be given an
interactive notebook where you can
perform a full assignment from beginning
to the end
kind of following partial instructions
and you know hopefully
being able to reproduce it for your own
data so and this is just an example so
inside those lessons you will be given
those links and you will be able to kind
of go through the full code and that
will be around a specific data set that
is described
a lot of different things are going to
be explained there visualization
of data
different
techniques for dimensionality reduction
including nmds pca and things like t-sne
working with different types of machine
learning techniques
and how to evaluate their performance
including confusion matrices and rock
curves
how to understand the methodology behind
a lot of these methods what do they
actually do behind the scenes so here's
an example of logistic regression for
example right how do we actually
understand what it does and how do we
develop a sense of
each one of these methods and and why we
would use one or the others and
where would we find the specific
settings for the way we want to use them
right so here's an example from uh you
know
how this would be implemented
in a particular language python with a
particular library scikit learn
also looking at different types of
conclusions how do you draw conclusions
from these methods because obviously
they are not straightforward and a big
challenge today is explainable ai so how
do we really explain how the model
worked why did it work the way that it
did and what do we
know about the output how do we
interpret the results now i think the
important part of that
is practicing some of these things in
the context of specific data sets right
so data sets that have been reviewed by
peers so there there are scientific
journal publications they have been
reviewed the findings have been
validated right how do we use those
examples
to really understand the terminology
that is used in a lot of these methods
and how do we actually start using them
to find similar kinds of insights about
the data so we have these curated data
sets this is an example cancer studies
using patient-derived cell lines in that
particular paper what the authors did
was they took a collection of breast
cancer cell lines and were able to
integrate multinomics data to develop a
prediction score for different types of
treatments measured on patients or sorry
measured on cell lines
so how to get access to all of this
training so as somalika already
mentioned a lot of these programs have
been designed around specific groups of
students so we've done these programs at
lsu with the louisiana biomedical
research network at georgetown
university medical center and even in
international programs like the image
university program in india and as a
result we have a lot of users that have
been able to kind of explore and
validate some of these
coursework and projects and really try
them for themselves and what we do along
the way is we collect feedback from some
of the users that we have and we want to
um you know kind of share a little bit
of that feedback today
just about some of the coursework so
if you have um you know i think an extra
30 minutes a day
and you wanted to get better at your
bioinformatics skills or try to use some
of these skills to perform a research
project we definitely recommend that you
go and just try the asynchronous version
of some of the coursework that we
described today
if you would really like to you know
quickly with the help of a mentor get
introduced to the topic and try to
understand how this topic could be used
in a context of a specific research
project we recommend the upcoming
training programs that we will have
starting in january so we will have a
program on genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics and data science
a webinar dedicated to data science is
going to take place this month next week
so we will be sending out some email
notifications about that if you would
like to join and kind of learn about
those topics in depth you're welcome to
join that as well
we also have a special program that is
called the research fellowship the
research fellowship program is designed
to not
train on any particular data type or
method but really to help you analyze a
data set of your own or a data set from
the public domain to develop an
independent research project
so that is an a rolling um kind of a
there is not a specific time to become a
part of that program it's a program that
you can join at any time and connect to
some of the mentors that we have that
could actually be
uh you know guiding you through that
process
okay how can you subscribe to the
newsletter well where all of the events
and webinars are around are announced
the best way is
if you already subscribed to this
particular webinar you probably received
an email from marketing at pine.bio
or marketing at
mxlogic.com
and there is um thank you sparse for
putting this link we have these
individual pages
for different upcoming programs that we
have for example this one is going to
start
on december 14th and we have a webinar
at 9 00 am so you will be able to find
this
and sparse if you could find the program
page that lists out all of the programs
you can share that as well so the best
thing i think is to add marketing and
find bio and marketing omixology.com to
your contact list and you will see a lot
of information coming from them too
announce different initiatives and
different types of programs that are
starting
okay so i i would like to finish
because we are running overtime by now
and just briefly mention
briefly mention
some of the opportunities for research
so
if you're a student
or if you are a
you know kind of a starting your your
research
as a faculty or a scientist uh you can
uh benefit from either
services that our team can provide just
helping analyze your data or joining a
cohort of students and faculty that are
learning to apply bioinformatics to
their research projects and so we have a
lot of examples specifically in
louisiana
and
yes if we can post a link here to the
research fellowship
so
this research fellowship program and
i'll just go through just a couple of
examples here
we've either collaborated with others on
doing research for them or you can you
know independently do the research on
your own i'll just share a link here
for that program
it's fellowship.omixlogic.com
it's a research program so really you
already know what you are interested in
and you would like to work with mentors
to
understand how to perform it well and
there's a couple of examples down here
at the bottom
you can also go to the main portal
and see some of the example projects if
you click right here on projects you
will find
other students have submitted some of
their projects
and what they look like
and um how can you contact us regarding
research so again if this is the type of
research you're looking for it's a
program that supports research projects
through training or if you would like to
have
us
if you would like to discuss any
research projects that you're working on
and they have a challenge in data
analysis
we also have a page dedicated to that as
well
okay and here you can find information
about the tt biometric platform
as well as some of the services that our
team provides and and what that
typically includes so
i hope that this is sufficient
information to kind of get started
and i'm sure that we will try to
organize this again in the near future
to
sorry expand on some of these topics
that we discussed today
so um sonalika are you still around
okay maybe not
so um i think that was the main
objective of the webinar today is to
just give you a high level overview of
what we do and how we do it
if you have any questions again i
mentioned those email addresses you're
free to well you're welcome to reach out
to them or if you would like to speak to
me directly my email is elia pine.bio
i'd be happy to hear about your feedback
or about any uh interest that you might
have
in the programs that we provide
and thank you dr torrea for inviting us
and again as i mentioned we're looking
forward to
to interacting with uh many of you
um and if you would like um
yes we do provide certificates uh these
are certificates that are supported by
the louisiana biomedical research
network as well as the national
association of idea principal
investigators and we will follow up with
an email
that will kind of highlight some of
these additional topics that you might
be interested in
so thank you for joining today
and
we
hope to stay in touch
and do this again one time
thank you unless anybody has any more
questions but what i'll do is i will
stop the recording